oh  no  no the 16-inch m1 max macbook pro  against the razer blade 15 advanced  let's compare the speakers  [Music]  apple finally updated to 1080p cameras  razer blade also comes with a 1080p  camera and now getting into performance  looks like multi-core it is 35 faster we  have 3d mark's new wildlife extreme  that's only a difference of six percent  we have blender opened up right here  looks like for blender for cpu tests the  performance isn't that huge of a  difference 3080 definitely takes the win  in graphics rendering let's export 50 of  those raw edited images and that took  three minutes and 24 seconds on battery  power i have davinci resolve opened up  i'm gonna go ahead and export this  project here macbook did a task in a  minute and 22 seconds i just was not  expecting the macbook to hold up so well